(upbeat music)
- What movie do you
want to watch, Sal?
- We got Faces of Death 10,
Amputee Fails, Cannibal Orgy?
- I've seen Cannibal
Orgy 100 times.
- You know what?
Why don't we just go
down to Mulcahey's
and hit on the waitress
with the sex tattoo?
Because these movies--
- You're just
saying that because
you're afraid of scary movies.
He pissed his pants last time
we watched Jason in Space.
- He doesn't belong in space!
- You want to talk scary movie?
I got a guy that will get
you a Norwegian horror movie
that will prolapse your colon.
- A pink sock.
- My man Olaf will
get you what you need.
All you have to do is go here.
The last time I watched
one of Olaf's movies,
I tried to bury myself.
- This Olaf guy?
He's not weird or
anything is he?
- No.
(woman screams)
- So you're uncle Sal sent ya.
Yeah he's a cool guy dudes.
So when do we get
to go swimming?
- Oh no we're, no swimming
we're just here to get
a horror movie from you.
- I do have
something very scary,
but I don't think
you can handle it.
- He's calling you out, dude.
- Yes I can.
- Drom Mord.
Norwegian horror
film about the demon
with an ice sword and an axe.
- Okay that sounds
perfect, I'll take that.
- Ah ah, you look like a
bunch of limp noodle dicks.
I'm pretty sure you
can't handle this.
- [Dan] I'm not scared.
- Okay.
Sweet dreams, Danny.
(laughs)
(howling)
- Drom Mord!
(whispering)
(yells)
- No I think we're good, I
think we're good with this.
I think it's good, we're good.
(laughs)
- Why did he kiss that girl?
- Yo I don't know man,
but we gotta go to sleep.
- Are you scared, is this
some Jason in Space shit?
- No!
- Oops.
- Dude are you trying
to Drom Mord me?
- Nope, just my
nightly Crisco mask.
Goodnight Danny.
(yelling)
I'm just kidding.
- Where'd you get that axe?
(farting)
Dude come on, that's
not even in the movie!
- I am out of ideas.
Ah dick!
I'll put my swamp
ass all over you.
- Have you gained
a couple pounds?
- Yep.
(creaking)
- Dude, enough of this shit.
- No, that wasn't me.
- Is mom home?
- No, she's at
ladies anatropics.
(whispering)
(yelling)
- Come on, come on, come on!
- Just the thing.
- You made an ice sword?
- I make a lot of ice weapons.
Let's roll.
- Oh come on man.
- Stay back, I got this.
(whispering)
(whimpering)
I got this!
Shit, shit!
Ice swords are fragile.
- I won't let my brother
get dream murdered.
- Neither will I.
(yelling)
- It's just a burglar,
just a burglar.
Let's get back to bed.
Gotta clean up that
ice in the morning.
(thunder booms)
- No more Norwegian shit dude.
- Yeah, turns out
those people are weird.
- Goodnight man.
- Goodnight.
(tinkly music)
- Shh.
(thunder booms)
(speaking Norwegian)